I'm very excited to announce that I have
teamed up with blonde medicine and I am
releasing the audio for my special Lefty
son as an album it drops Friday
September 22nd everywhere you get music
iTunes Apple music Spotify you name it
it'll be out there very excited go check
it out support my special on YouTube
thank you very much
guys we got the dates for 2023 locked
maybe a couple more added Phoenix I'll
see you guys September 29th and the 30th
La Jolla I'll be back October 20th
through the 22nd Salt Lake City finally
coming back October 27th and the 28th
hoping to see you all out there Batavia
Illinois my first time going there very
excited coming on November 10th and
November 11th and San Francisco to close
out the year at Cobbs cannot wait to get
back to one of my favorite cities in the
country December 8th and 9th all tickets
are available on my website at
ryansickler.com
the Honeydew with Ryan sickler
[Applause]
welcome back to the Honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
Studios I am Ryan sickler I'm Ryan
sickler.com I'm Ryan Cyclone all your
social media I want to say thank you
guys this community continues to grow
the numbers on YouTube are up
um I appreciate everything you're doing
please go support the special Lefty son
if you haven't watched it yet go watch
it share it comment do all that we're
pumping that for a year I saw Tyler the
Creator say you gotta pump your own
stuff for a year and I'm gonna listen to
Tyler the Creator because he's [__]
Tyler the Creator so uh there's that and
if you gotta have more then you gotta
have the patreon the Honeydew with y'all
is the craziest show on patreon I
guarantee it for five dollars it's five
bucks all right and you get the Honeydew
a day early you get it ad free you get
it at no additional cost and
again we just had the guy the old man
and his his wife were held hostage by a
convict that killed a dude he escaped
with and set the car on fire the old man
gets away gets a handgun out of his
pickup truck and they have a [__]
Showdown five dollars okay a cup of
coffee you're getting hundreds of
episodes of this craziest [__] they're
your stories so if you or someone you
know has a story that's got to be heard
submitted the Honeydew podcast gmail.com
hopefully good to do an episode with you
and if you're looking for a new podcast
to listen to I'm telling you go listen
to my old podcast to crab Feast the crab
Feast is a storytelling podcast I did
with Jay Larson and everyone in
podcasting you know and love has been on
it Burr Chrysler Segura Christina P
everybody they're all in there and that
download that library is going to do a
million downloads this year it's insane
the community's still so wildly active
and I'm telling you it's a good good
listen so check it out there's a seven
and a half year Library all right and if
you are in town when I am around come
see me on tour the live and Alive tours
rolling September 29th and 30th Phoenix
Arizona October 20th and through the
22nd La Jolla California October 27th
28th Salt Lake City November 10th and
11th Batavia Illinois December 8th and
9th San Francisco California that's it
you guys know what we do over here we
highlight the low lights I always say
these are the stories behind the
storytellers I'm very excited to have
this guest on here y'all first time on
the Honeydew ladies and Gentlemen please
welcome Jared freed welcome to the
Honeydew thank you for having me such a
pleasure to be here I love watching a
chef cook I love watching that that
intro you know what I was thinking when
you were doing that because I do I'm a
big intro guy like I look at an intro
it's necessary sets up the show
introduces what we got going on you give
your dates we are comedians are the only
people or podcasters I guess I would say
who thank you the first thing we do
thank you like
that's how much we appreciate like I do
the same because I just take podcasts
for myself I just did an alone episode
of my show and I start with I can't
thank you enough like and it's like you
know you could be doing you could be
doing anything you [__] want right
you opted in to this show and we we say
thank you I think it's important to
acknowledge like you know you think
friends is starting with thank you for
watching friends tonight
[__] [__]
right right
Seinfeld doesn't come out the beginning
of Seinfeld hey I just want to thank you
guys for tuning in to my [__] no
they're like you should take what we put
out there you I don't know the whole
dynamic of entertainment has changed and
that's not saying anything new but like
the idea we really do appreciate like
because look at I walked in here you
have a business there's a you know
there's a real business that is is
making me feel good about myself you
sure this is a beautiful thing this is
amazing people are employed some people
who are they family business today
that's what this is this is and you're
supporting a family business this is and
you're putting joy we allow people as
podcasters to take their brain and put
it on the shelf for an hour whatever it
might be and get away from their
thoughts and it's the most intimate art
form we are inside of people's bodies
isn't that weird yeah people put airpods
in is the only thing we're in them yeah
it's intimate and also they're they're
they're getting to know an hour each
week of Jared and not uh you know Don
the the bookkeeper that you play on a
sitcom
they don't like you because they love
this character over here they know you
well that's made then they root you on
harder when you go be Don the bookkeeper
or whatever absolutely or they you know
it's made stand up you have to be more
committed to your stand-up and what you
do on stage it's a different thing yep
than what's going on here with you and I
like this is to get to know the person
and like yeah then you say oh you gotta
go I just met this guy he seemed like a
night someone I'd be cool yeah we've
never met before yeah I'm a big fan I
can tell you're a good girl goes both
ways you can really tell
um but before and I appreciate
everything you're saying but I'm here to
support you now so before we get into
this plug promote everything and
anything social media specials all of us
a special 37 and single is out on
Netflix it is I I want everyone to go
watch it that's it it's on Netflix 37
single you can type in j-a-r and I come
up right next to the movie Jarhead hell
yeah
I just already looked it up
so when does this come out I don't even
know uh a couple weeks yeah okay so it's
out yeah it's called 37 and single
if you've been in your 30s if you've
been single if you've had friends give
you advice on being single if you've
been to a gender reveal party if you
have body issues if you have parents if
you're Jewish you're gonna love it
that's it it's fun I'm not in the
business of I come to your town and
upset you and change your mind I am
there to make you laugh and if you're I
my audience is generally women
um I think when men watch my show with
their girlfriend or significant other
they are seen in a in the light who they
truly are which is a [__] disgusting
idiot who's a little bit more vulnerable
than people know
and it likes to have fun a lot more you
know because when we go on stage
you know I I because I get my audience
is mainly women I get a lot of women
that come because I give dating advice
I've been talking about dating for well
you also I don't mean interrupt you but
you also do this favorite ick thing that
I love and I laughed the other day
because I saw one where the girl said
the towel on the shoulder that's totally
my move
right you put the towel
come on [__] now that's like that's
the thing that's the thing and you know
the ick there's a so there's an egg bit
on the special yeah yeah and the whole
reason I do that you know everyone's
putting out crowd work clips
to go ahead have at it but I had this
bit where I talk about the ick and not
understanding it because it's not a very
guy thing straight guy thing
and then I went to the crowd I go does
anyone have a fun ick and women were
yelling out the most
hilariously specific things just like a
guy looking at the ick being something
that just drives them can't stand will
not [__] that guy like ever it's ruined
I saw this one thing
that's the it and it's wonderful
confident men can laugh at it yeah the
least confident men get angry they go
you all you're just a towel on your
shoulder and you go oh you tell me
you're [__] throwing up two towels on
my shoulder you know what I'm saying
right one woman's it is another woman's
husband yeah fun part
I say that on the show because I had to
tell because then women would yell you
know again everyone's angry everyone's
not confident so like there's male
versions of not confidence and there's
female version not go you know you'd
have some woman that would yell like bad
breath and I'm like well that's not a
dick that's a turn off you know that's
no one in the room I always say I I have
to set it up because now people have
seen the videos and they want to yell
their ex and I'm like I have to set up
like some things are just turn offs and
also it needs to be women I think
because guys will sleep with anything
you know what I mean go watch the BET go
watch the bed I explained yeah listen
it's not the most [__] genius bit in
the world but it's it's so I explained
basically how little I understand that
because there's no ick right you know we
it doesn't matter whatever whatever and
that's the thing you know when they say
women dress for other women guys dress
for other women you know we want to be
[__] so the idea of a guy getting
knocked off is [__] stoop a little
bit is funny yeah for sure and I'll come
down so I love doing the okay because so
it started as that so I was like I do
the bit I open it and then I go does
anyone have a neck and then I get all
the crowd work bits the clips I want and
it's a fun part of the show and then I
do the end of the and that's what it was
over uh the course of a year so but
that's a special this is a go watch this
yeah go and if you like the best
Bachelor you can what is it 37 and 37 in
seconds and single it's on Netflix it's
like it's been the greatest time of my
life just the last couple weeks like
getting to like put it out there you
know it's so I'm it's exciting
um now let's get to know a little bit
about you you and I were talking before
the show so you're from Massachusetts
Massachusetts yeah you're a Jewish
Jewish
brother you said you have a bro one
younger brother four years younger all
right
um and then I got two parents still
together they live in Boca now they're
like they made the Jewish migration
because that's really is it's Boca
specifically I hear that a lot I mean
they are literally like it's hard to
tell people because it's a punch line
yeah yeah but is there a large community
of Jewish people in Boca are you alive
I didn't know you didn't know and it was
old but I didn't know
yeah you know and it's Northeast Jews
all retired all in communities the
communities are like little tiny summer
camps okay they all know have
reputations of their own and my parents
are like I mean at the end of my special
I put hidden cameras in the Green Room
to tape my parents yelling at me so if
you go to the credits of my special yeah
it's my parents why are they yelling at
you just because that's what they do
they they were like I was like my my
original idea was I want my parents like
giving me [__] in the way they do and
then I want to smash I want to open with
my parents being like you did this you
wore that what are you wearing what's
going on and then cut to me on stage I'm
37 and single
it got too confusing
I think for people who knew me it was
funny but like as a stand-up special
like you would just want to get let's
get into it so we put it in the credits
they still don't know it hasn't come out
yet so they still don't know that there
was hidden cameras in the Green Room
so we taped and it's like
and it was funny because before when we
were leading into it you know Lavin you
know homeless pimp who made me special
he was like he's the best and he goes
how are we gonna get them to like say
[__] I go
you're gonna have so much [__] [__]
we're gonna have b-roll yeah and he and
he goes you don't want to like make sure
they have like a line to say to you I go
if you give them a line they won't be
good at it I was like and we got done
taping and laugh and looked at me he's
like this is [__] crazy because it's
my mom being like take a picture of us
no you take the worst pictures and then
it's my dad the makeup woman walks in he
goes I told her make you look tan like
it's [__] it's just yeah parent [__]
yeah
so we have all that so like yeah my
parents like all we do is scream and
yell and
it's like it's just the whole thing like
it's um and right now like I'm on the
road I'm doing a different hour than the
special and it's all about my family and
it's like this idea that like
you know I'm 38 and it's weird that like
I'm in this like business relationship
with them like I do feel like I like
hanging out with them we are together a
lot it's just they give me [__] in ways
that if a stranger did I wouldn't speak
to that person again you know like
everything's oh yeah a battle
everything's an explanation why would
you do it this way even this week I flew
here on Thursday
and then I went back to New York on
Saturday yeah and then came back here on
Sunday that's nuts nuts I don't I and my
dad goes where are you and I go I go I
didn't explain it to you because you
wouldn't understand and then he goes
what do you mean I go I flew here
Thursday then I flew back on Saturday
then I flew back on Sunday to LA and he
goes
yeah you're right I wouldn't understand
yeah so end of conversation just don't
ask any questions so tell me about your
dad you said uh well you brought up
business small business family business
here what did your dad do for a living
He wholesale liquor beer and wine okay
so like which is for himself or he
worked for a company like what did he it
was a family but it was like my
grandparents my family
um and it was like you know a long time
my you know what my dad has three
siblings they everyone was involved in
everything and then they also did
nursing home stuff and just ran nursing
homes and assisted care living
facilities so and then those just slowly
kind of like
got sold and that was it but my dad was
always like encouraged you know you got
to go help the family type of thing and
I think when I started doing comment he
to my brother and I he was always like
go away he was good with that
there was no it was it wasn't going to
happen that way just that wasn't even an
option to not want you to do this it
didn't see it just never came up it you
know one got sold when I was in
like high school whatever and the other
he like went and worked at and helped
with and it just wasn't it wasn't like
we're gonna go third generation on this
right you know like that wasn't even a
thought and you know to Aussie was like
you know very much a supporter of like
go to like I went to Penn State and I
like he's like go to New York New York
is where it happens
well I don't know what but that's where
successful people go yeah you know go do
something
yeah and he would always say you can't
do nothing
and I'm like that's helpful thanks
car dealerships it's new to you yeah
can't do nothing I was like well how
about a little Direction here so yeah I
was just like a you know I went to a
state school you're living in unreality
you know like Penn State is like the
thickest bubble
you just go there and party and have fun
and there's no person in that town who
could hire you one day yeah you know so
you're kind of the top of the pecking
order and you don't give a [__] [__]
so you you know I walked around in an
Elvis wig and overalls at football games
yeah so I was like a [__] idiot and I
you know had fun made the friends of my
life you know like all that stuff and
then
yeah so my family like growing up like
it was like
just a lot of ball busting like just a
lot of like my dad is a big family you
know so that's where we come from like
it's like hey [__] right like you say
that to a regular person they're like
what do you call me an ass like and it
derails I'm like no that's just that's
hello like that's just getting your
attention you know
yeah even my grandmother my grandmother
my grandmother brought her to a show in
Boston I opened for Steve Sweeney I was
like Steve Sweeney is the biggest
[__] Boston comic ever I go open for
I bring her to Nick's comedy stop they
had it in like a ballroom at that point
like it was just a different type of
Club than it was in the past
I remember my grandmother was sneaking
nips
the airplane vodkas and she kept pouring
her own drink which she always did that
wasn't new to me right yeah and
I got off stage and the owner of the
booker Ryan he's like we just saw your
grandmother pouring her own drinks I you
know that's how we make money like
what's going on in my mouth and I he's
like can you talk to your grandma I was
like
not going to talk to my grandmother
about her drinking habits
and
and I go Nana like but also [__] let
the lady have a right drinks bro what
are you what do you what's it really
setting you back four dollars I'll pay
it thank you like what is thank you
right come on and I don't know why I did
I went and talked to her
I go now they saw you pouring your
drinks gonna stop like and I'm also like
the young comic I'm trying to figure
[__] out I'm trying to get booked again
of course and she goes I don't know what
you're talking about like full Criminal
just total criminal activity
I was like man I know what you know what
I'm talking about and she was like we
can he can go [__] in this half that's
it that's her yeah that's a good one
right that's such an old person thing to
say I don't even know what it means yeah
so yeah that's like but that's an
example like that's how she was like
it's just everyone was fired up yeah but
that's Boston too like everyone's just
ready to like listen right it's uh
Gaffigan and I talked about this from
the Mid-Atlantic up is just an angry
aggressive [__] talking
[__] thick-skinned location better be
[__] ready for it right you're just
better it's not even personal sometimes
right it's just some [__] talking right
I it's funny like we took those crowd
work Clips you see a lot of comics posts
together and it's like sometimes I see
people you know it's just like you
weren't Built For This you see people
post them you go this isn't it nature
you know like and you know you're cut
you got a cousin that's 20 times funnier
over there at the house dropping them
left and right right and I could if I
came back to my cousin with that the
whole room would go what the [__] yeah
what are you talking about yeah yeah all
right so there's two stories I really
want to hear about we talked earlier you
had an accident when you were younger I
want to talk about this do you remember
what you said so yeah I got my license
and were you 16 when you got it 16 and a
half okay is what you got your license
it's funny because all these revolve
around football
we love football your next story does
too I know so I love it but I I'm a
football fan okay who do you grow up
like are you Patriots you know and
the Patriots now gets this like
reputation that you're like all of a
sudden because they were good you're a
bandwagon like I think like my dad and
his best friend were always just like
big Patriots they like loved it I think
they were also the types like Foxboro
like the people who I guess that's
generally football fans like
it's a you know Blue Collar we're gonna
scream and yell the whole game type you
know baseball's a little more reserved
you know a little more again you can you
see your people there but it's like you
know there's people that go to a game
after work right you know football
Sunday yeah
like we used to go to the Patriots game
and we went my whole life my family we
always had season tickets to everything
like because my dad liquor business you
give them out oh hell yeah you know so
he we always had tickets we always had
the game and we were even
at the snowball game I'll never forget
are you really the one with the snowplow
guy came through no no that's an older
one that's the old snowball game okay
the Brady Tuck Rule game oh the yeah
yeah yeah we called you you're a
snowball it was my brother dad and I
were in the stands we see Brady go back
ball pops out my dad goes let's [__]
go he collects us all I'm in high school
my brother's in middle school we start
running out of the stadium we start
going you know if the stadium is like
this we're on this side so we're running
across the stadium to get to my dad's
car and then we're on we're literally at
the goal line of you go past this point
you're not allowed back in we hear the
crowd go [__] nuts and we're like we
gotta go back we turn around we go to
seats that weren't even ours and they
overturned the call now it's not a
fumble Patriots ball
they kick a field goal I'll never forget
it we're in the stands and it's the last
game of Foxboro Stadium this guy next to
us is just peeing in the The Stand yeah
and he's pissing and I remember I'm in
high school he looks at me and goes I
can't miss this game
it just wouldn't leave
that's like what was going on and that's
the type of animals who go to games
like
I remember we used to sit in front of
this one family my and my my dad and my
dad's best friend I think growing up
used to go to Patriots games like and
the Patriots were always the fourth team
like yeah they weren't the Patriots that
now people have they weren't the evil
empire the 85 team and then that was
pretty much it that's it and the Celtics
the Red Sox first the Celtics and then
the Bruins is a different crew but
always popular always
Patriots and my dad and his best friend
we used to watch every song that was
when we ate like that was when we made
brought in special food to our house
like that was like a big deal to me like
that's a warming feeling for me yeah and
I remember they used to talk about a guy
that sat behind them and would get
[__] tanked and the whole game would
go hit him hey him annihilate him hit
him so my uncle who's my dad's best
friend we used to call him Uncle Steve
he'd Go the whole game hey
so then we do that like we have these
like things it's like you know football
was always just a part of like
everything and
I remember I got my license 16 and a
half I'm born in February so I'm getting
my license in the summer right that
would make sense math wise and
we had preseason Patriots tickets and my
dad's like go with your brother go to
the game what Freedom you know like
your first time driving
and you got your 12 year old bro he's
four years younger four years younger
yeah so you got a 12 year old and we get
to be on our own and do whatever the
[__] we want
yeah yeah by the way I haven't asked you
or your brother do either of you I know
you say you're single but do either of
you have kids no he's engaged okay
um
yeah he's engaged and she's great and
but also like he got engaged older you
know he's 33 34. you know like we it's
really been like the four of us like
it's like and we do all
I I'm very lucky I understand when
families kind of go their own ways yeah
we're all very much alike like the
things we were late on food Sports
ball busting you know we're in a way
that I know it's a lucky thing you don't
that just doesn't happen yes I know
family Dynamics are hard
some people can't let [__] go
you know and then other people come into
your family my dad used to always say my
Dad gives the my dad says things I don't
think he realizes are good but he also
it's always sounds a little [__] up so
he's like it's not that he'd like be
next to my mom he's like he'd go it's
not the family that argues it's the
people that marry in and rip you apart
and he is right
I don't know if you say that next to my
mom
like he says [__] like that and I go I
know what you're saying like I've always
played the part of empathy person my
whole life
like there's not like I've always had
the I see what you're saying even though
it's not in a way I will I can see the I
can make that a little more palatable
it's my yeah it's probably if I'm gonna
give myself credit it's my best quality
and it's my quality that wastes my time
the most
because I'm sitting there thinking of
how did you come from that
angle and but I
when he said that I was like he is right
because when you're in a family Dynamic
you go that's a place I'm gonna say
something
that's a place I'm not and the place you
don't is where your wife or girlfriend
or whoever comes in and goes you better
say something about it yeah you're right
you better
[__] [__] right now they got the ick
I don't get [__] because I didn't tell
my dad to shut the [__] up and stop
asking me questions you know what I mean
100 and this probably all has a reason
I'm 37. this is probably why I live in
fear of commitment I'm like we got a
good hair
you know yeah you don't want to break
this up right oh so this is all that
Yoko that you don't want coming in you
know breaking up to 40 Beatles I live in
fear of them yeah I because I like it
I'm having fun
so it works for you it works for me
there's no quick fix for anxiety and
depression it's not finding a new
therapist or starting an exercise
routine it's not more in regular
meditation or a better diet sometimes
you need something to unlock your brain
and a new way of thinking about and
seeing the world and maybe that thing is
guided ketamine therapy from mind Bloom
there's a new tool to improve your
mental health it's at home ketamine
therapy mind Bloom is the leader in at
home ketamine therapy having safely
helped thousands of people overcome
their anxiety and depression unlike
traditional talk therapy ketamine Works
quickly and doesn't have the unpleasant
side effects of traditional
antidepressants in a study of over 1 200
mind-bloom clients 89 percent reported
improvements in their anxiety and
depression after only two sessions right
now mind Bloom is offering my listeners
100 off your first six session program
when you sign up at mindbloom.com
Honeydew and you use the promo code
honey do take the first step and break
free from your anxiety and depression
with mind Bloom mindbloom.com honeydew
and use promo code honeydew now let's
get back to the dude so so you and your
brother
to a preseason game
if you've ever been to Foxboro Stadium
it's not a very easy place to get to one
Road's out there right it's out there
it's you know 45 minutes from Boston but
like from my house it wasn't 45 you know
it's an okay drive
so we go out there and I've done it a
million times even at that age what are
you driving
Jeep Liberty okay okay little mini uh
medium SUV medium it was my car I was
given a car right away wow so that tells
you everything you need to know about my
family background yeah which I'm okay
with
some you you know some have one uh have
a Jeep some people get the whole Corolla
that's what I
mean
there's some yeah yeah yeah those in
every comedian will try and outpour me
not hard to do I'm not trying I'm just
laughing if that's the exact [__]
cool is it really yeah it really is no
okay so you guys are in a Jeep Liberty
Jeep or brand new
navy blue what color is it black Okay so
and this relates to the other story that
my grandfather like was like I got you
my grandfather was always spoiling me
like my mom's dad my mom's from Michigan
he spoiled me to death I was the first
grandson
he is like uh he's an amazing person he
was he was an amazing person like uh but
to me I could do not it was always
I was the number one out so I think
that's a big grandparent thing your
first one you know I I think I don't
know I would assume I mean I'm a dad I
can imagine my daughter's first child is
going to be a big deal yeah right you're
gonna go the one and you'll get
everything yeah and you get to be
Grandpa yeah that's what I'm saying your
mate you made him a grandfather right
yeah so
I think he was just like
card you know whatever you want so
we're driving to Foxboro which is like a
little not a dry you know a little bit
of a drive and it's a one it's like kind
of a one-lane highway to get into the
stadium and it's not really a great
drive it's actually known for that so
what they did is they took they had a
median in the road and they took the
other side of the street and they made
it Go a different way than it normally
goes so I in the car drift out to that
lane that normally goes East and is now
going west okay yeah there's a cop on a
motorcycle I'm a month into a license
there's a cop on a motorcycle who I know
for a fact didn't remember that they
made the show the road that goes east go
west so he's looking so wait you're
actually going the right way I'm going
the right way you're going the correct
way right he's not he's looking the
other way and I know I'm right because
if I was
the way the crash happened he crashed so
then I'm coming in and he turns into the
side of my car
and I'm like oh my God
I'm like in traffic but he's also on a
motorcycle so that's deadly even as you
go down right but if he again to crash
into the the side of my car from that
position you have to be looking the
other way yeah it's not my it I've
looked thought about this a million
times it couldn't have been my fault
but I'm 16 and a half
and and a month he's a cop and he's a
cop and it's a bike
my life is over we pull over the car I'm
like look at my brother I'm like [__]
[__] [__] I'm screaming I'm like I'm
done it's over I hit a cop yeah
it's bad on a bike and I'm like [__] and
they come over I'm like I'm sorry
immediately it's my fault I did
everything oh no right like I'm not
sitting there being like [__] you
[__] guys what the [__] he's looking
the wrong way my brand new Liberty got
there yeah it's a brand new car
ah come on my Grandpa bought this for me
you know getting cocky yeah I'm a
[__] junior in high school
so we went I remember
I had to like go to court
and like show up in court and they're
like and you see banged up or was he no
they let me off the hook but made it
sound like
they were doing me a favor
which isn't the case if I look back now
I'm like no you're all just gonna like
cover for one another oh yeah
you don't want this cop gonna get known
like
no 16 year old kid right and you [__]
up and I think like the idea like I
remember them being like oh he's been
getting [__] about it like yeah he was
getting [__] about did he turned the
wrong way he forgot which way the street
was going you know they all I know that
yeah
and they're like we're gonna let you off
you know this is a good Learning lesson
and I'm like
it wasn't the lowest point in my life
but it definitely was like it just it's
a hell of a way to start your driving
[__] record yeah bro and now I got my
mom you drive too slow it's like well
you didn't
day one day right I'm a little [__]
day [__] ruined yeah dude that's
terrible terrible
um I want to hear this other story
involves football this is one that you
said uh we were going to talk about and
this is interesting so then the Patriots
get good again not just football it's
Patriots again too it's the Patriots
Patriots go to the Super Bowl which one
is this of your what nine nine or
whatever it is the helmet catch game all
the David Tyree David Tyree so I don't
know what year this was whatever it was
I was selling life insurance and I'm
making cold calls every day I'm [__]
miserable this is the life I'm again go
to New York City do something you can't
do nothing right
and I'm there and honestly I was just
like there kind of parking my car like
I'm just like let me figure out what I
want and which direction I want to go to
but also
you know they're going to do this job
and at first I was like giving it a
gung-ho like maybe this will be my
career and then when you learn something
isn't you start going okay let me figure
out what what's the next move and I my
idea my thing was I would you know I
I didn't want to do the next thing
unless I was going to Sprint at it
I hear you on that you know what I mean
yeah so like
and even at a young age I was like
disillusioned with like I could feel
that I was like part of this like
someone else's grift
you know life insurance like I was on a
team but it wasn't really a team this
guy just needed numbers to get you know
you could feel that and then some people
succeed and I'm sure they do well and I
actually was jealous of people who loved
their job like I was like like you'd see
like these people they come and they'd
convince themselves that they were like
I'm Gordon Gekko right you could
there are people and you go it's
flappable but if anyone who's ever sold
life insurance there's someone there
who's crushing
there's the uh Tom Brady of life
insurance no doubt yeah there's someone
that makes out but they go through a lot
of people too nah real estate same thing
you know selling Sunset you know like
there's people that they got the slick
back hair they got the good look and
they got the cool car and you go this
must be an easy giant you go no you have
to be you know good at this and
delusional yeah you know like to be able
to sing dancing but I I was jealous of
the idea like I don't like when
someone's like oh you got out of that to
be a comedian good for you wow you're
out of the Rat right I'm like no there's
everyone there's someone in every
industry who's and I think what happens
is you get
I remember when I left selling life
insurance I was like
I was like they kind of like when you're
in an office space you're like this is
the only way to make a hundred grand and
then when you get out of that do you
know what I mean yeah
and you could add to that you go I was
there for sure what did you do I wrote
and produced promos and upfront
presentations and Sizzle reels and
produced and directed for
networks for a long long time day time
and at night time I would still do and
weekends I would tour and do comedy wow
I mean and you probably looked at
someone in that production world and was
like that's the guy yeah or you know the
person whatever it was that's the one I
if I really did it a certain way I'd end
up there I'd be that guy right and then
you then I don't want to be that guy
right you slowly realize you don't have
the energy for it no like I literally
physically
comedy I've always had the energy
you know it's easy when you love it
right it's easy to you know it's not
easy but you know what I mean it's it's
way better than dragging yourself to a a
place that you hate you know whether
it's whatever I'm going to Jiffy Lube
today and I'm changing oil and I [__]
hate it then do something about it well
I used to always think of like I played
football my whole life or I played Pop
Warner then I played high school and I
was always like I I wasn't built for it
like as a human
but I was always like good at it like I
played d-line as a smaller I wasn't like
a six foot five three you know like but
I remember in high school
they'd be like scout team and I would
run out there
and
the the best feeling in the world and
I'm telling High School football stories
yes I know how much of a [__] loser
this makes me but I remember the best
feeling in the world was being a
sophomore on the scout team who
embarrassed the [__] out of the senior
yeah you know I they'd be doing the
drills the first team and I'd
somehow figure out a way and because I
was pretty good at you know whatever and
I I'd ruin their practice and then
they'd do the thing they grab your who
is this
this guy this [__] loser that's what
they do yeah
and it was really an insult to you yeah
you know what I'm talking about you just
piece of [__] right here
this [__] loser what's your name
you didn't even have your name on your
helmet just a [__] loser you let this
loser right
you you know and the guy who you're
it's like wait a minute I did well you
know not good job
good job this piece of trash just owned
you football is the most instructive
thing right and there's like it is so
much and I that was the best feeling in
the world to me I just love that and I
was like
hey this happened my whole life I
remember my I'll tell you another story
this is and I'm gonna get believe me
I'll get to them
but football is very important to me I
was a junior and I started as d-line as
a junior which not a lot of people in my
class did
I'll never forget it I mean this I was
we're playing against Framingham it was
under the lights
and
framingham's driving out of their own
20.
quarterback rolls to the left I go to
meet him if he's gonna run I start
sprinting that way throws it I catch it
intercepted I ran for a touchdown hell
yeah so I ran it under the lights
I like Turned I I had another video
they didn't even play that well that's
how shitty we were this is Boston high
school sports it's [__]
you know I do like a fist pump I look
like a [__] idiot and I'll never
forget we go in the locker room and it
was like before half time and I remember
like these two guys who I played
football with growing up they were a
year older they're going Jared freed
scored a touchdown that loser like they
were talking about it as if like us like
like a Make-a-Wish kid
did it like they go cool what can you
believe of all the people and I'm going
I'm right here I played with you I've
been good my what am I delusional
like was I delusional my oh my God I
have been pretty good my whole life yeah
like good hey got those good soft hands
man bro what are they talking about I
was but that is one of those moments you
hear someone say exactly what they think
of you
and you're like oh I remember
um I I was wrestling one year right
after my my father had died just like
three months before this and um I'm in
this tournament it's like a holiday
wrestling tournament so it's December
and or it's like February and it's you
know 12 different schools from the
surrounding area come and meet and
you're doing an all-day tournament and
[__] and they asked me to wrestle a
class up and you know if the guy's fat I
got it but if he's solid with muscle
it's it's a long ass day you do your
type yeah and
um they put me up against this kid
that's just a monster and I'm I'm giving
up at least 15 pounds I'm on the scale
with a pudding cup eating it with my
singlet and everything on and it's not
even budging right
and I go in and um I am definitely
supposed to lose this coach like listen
just don't get pinned we you know just
try to stay don't get pinned we don't
need that just just fight them on the
team for the team I'm like okay I go in
this dude's a big [__] and he
just did you wrestle as well he I just
gave him you know a little check his
head and I just Chuck him by me a little
bit and his neck just sticks out far
enough
and I was like [__] it and I threw a
headlock on them and flipped them and
dropped on them and then I took that arm
and I shoved it over his [__] mouth
and nose and I rocked and I didn't just
rock I prayed
that I would hear the because I knew if
I didn't this kid's gonna get up and
he's gonna [__] me I knew he made a
mistake and I caught right you got him
on a bad day that's it yeah he stuck it
out just a little too far I noticed it
everything works in my favor and then I
hear the boom and the kid gets pissed I
win he doesn't want to [__] shake my
hand the whole thing your team must have
went [__] not coach is going nuts I'm
going nuts yeah we get on the bus coach
is giving out awards at the end but
instead of saying this one goes out to
you know uh guy who had them also also
ended up being the fastest pin in the
entire tournament right could have said
there's a lot of positives here this guy
goes this award right here goes out to
the guy who Shoulda never won
there's no way he should have we already
had him down for a pit you know you know
what I mean I'm just like man there's a
one there's a way who won US the meat
it was such an important moment for me
because I was like man I was just so
angry with everything with my dad died
confused and everything and I go out
there boom I go in the locker room and I
just break down have just a wall of
emotion just right
and then to get on there and he says
that [__] I'm just like this is what
also you know you're not like the thing
is like there's a thing where it's like
not every time has to be a comeback down
to earth yeah you know you got lucky you
know this is a one in a lifetime moment
this wasn't you know that's the annoying
part yeah it's like I don't need to be
reminded right I knew it when I was like
God don't get up go get up oh God I
squeeze it everything I have like oh God
don't do it you heard it you had your
Rocky moment you had your [__] habit
bro let me have yeah and then they gotta
remind you well we still don't think
you're [__] yeah but here's the paper
right right
yeah so tell me what happened so this is
all to say that yeah when I was doing
the life insurance thing I wasn't really
like enjoying my life
um and when I do stand up that was the
only thing when I remember when I
started doing stand-up that was the only
thing that felt like that scouty moment
you could just go to an open mic and go
and do it you could just go to any you
get on stage every day just by signing
your name on a list same as scout team
like I don't know I had such energy for
that who we need we need scout team
Sprint right out we gotta Open Mic
Sprint right out like I I just always
had that feeling that was akin to
the the scout team feeling I was
literally running through mud when I was
doing the life insurance like I just was
like I can't wake up in the morning I
don't feel great
but New York City in the fall when
you're [__] in your 20s I don't think
there's a better place in the world to
be football Sundays that's when
everyone's you know it's a transplant
town so it's not like you're right so
like here too right so football Sunday's
in a bar in LA and New York those are
the greatest times to meet people have
make new friends be around this like
kind of like group that is bigger than
just the people you moved to the city
with everyone's got their people from
work or from friends from high school
friends from Camp whatever it was that
was a really good place to meet people
so I had this like group that we would
go out Sundays and get hammered watch
the games and then that was it so I like
loved Sundays in football
so the Patriots
they go on they're the best that It Ever
Was That season they're the undefeated
season oh this is the end right because
that was the thing that broke so
undefeated season everyone's talking
Patriots every week's a party
and my grandfather again is like I want
to send you guys the Super Bowl
and I'm like I I'm like yeah this is the
Dream Season they're undefeated
my grandfather who [__] spoils me on
everything like he's like I'm sending
you if they go we're go you're going
and I'm like yeah [__] of course and my
cousin and his friends who happen to be
going so
it was in Arizona
Sons is out there and I go and
there's not a lot of hanging out like
you know if you're not have you ever
been to a Super Bowl no
here's the thing about going to the
Super Bowl it's not that fun it's very
corporate if you're not it seems like it
to me like it would be it would be fun
or no it would be not fun it would be
very like regimented and like we're
doing this corporate event over here for
Coca-Cola and Xerox or whatever the [__]
you have to have a lot of money to have
fun it sounds like you and if you don't
you're just kind of like one of those
people at the NFL experience holding a
Big Bud Light
hahaha
this is not a play if you don't got
money yeah not a lot of places to sit
you got the tall boy NFL experience
right you're just like walking through a
big [__] stupid kids thing with a
beer so we were like it was like the Fry
Saturday night before and it's like what
are we gonna do so we're like let's go
to a strip club like let's go
and we go and
I'm like
you know we walk in and they're like do
you guys want to go to the back we're
like yeah [__] yeah like how much and it
was like 100 bucks each it was like I
remember being reasonable and you're
like yeah let's go to the [__] bag
it's reasonable
and I don't like telling the story
because I I it really is like I'm not a
strip club guy you know I'm not just
going strip clubs every time you know
like
I'm not proud of it I'm like I'm also 24
23 but I'm putting this out because I I
don't want to like I just anytime a
strip club comes up I'm like I I've been
knowing you know I don't like strip club
guys like have you ever been on The
Bachelor was like there's that guy that
needs to go like I'm not a roommate I
had a roommate that was gone you know on
Wednesdays yeah no that's not I don't
know I know you know especially I've
always been like a single guy like I
want to be around women that might want
to actually keep it you know like so
yeah I'm just not that guy I don't know
and there are those guys and that's
it's all okay but so we go they bring us
in the back and we are getting drunk and
I'm like
I don't know when this happened but
they're like do you want to stay and I
just remember taking I had a money clip
and I remember taking out my wallet and
I'm like it's just explodes everywhere
and one of the people picks up my card
like come on let's go and I'm like yeah
and honestly that's the last thing I
remember
I don't have any
and we just wake up there there yeah oh
man you got drugged big time so you
definitely did there's no question in my
mind
and it's my cousins and I and who are
all the same people you were with are
still there and we're just like what you
know my question what time did you get
there roughly I don't even remember it's
so long ago and also like what time do
you wake up like morning morning it was
like that scene in Varsity Blues yeah
they walk out and we're like is the club
still going
I we were like let's get out of here
yeah like it wasn't like I just remember
being like in here to vacuum like
time to go and we're like
and it didn't really hit me the drugging
thing because I'm like I have to assume
now that's what happened it's only
because of that movie hustlers
the Jennifer Lopez I've never seen that
one I think it was like they were like
yeah it's based on true story they took
advantage of these [__] losers and
I'm like yeah I'm the loser you know
like I'm going
and I think it's cardi B that got in
trouble for saying that they used to do
that the strip club the guys and Rob
them as well I they took a thumbprint to
like make it you know like it's very
hard to like just when you have the the
signature in the thumbprint they did
that wait
they took your thumbprint and did the
signature for how much on the card how
much 10 grand no
10 grand
free they got 10 grand on a credit card
on what did they cash it out it's just
done I didn't even ask questions I just
had to receive my pocket and you're like
what the [__] and now we're going to the
game and I'm like are you do you have
enough
we just and it was my dad's car so my
dad and again I'm like 23 I've got a
card attached to him I'm trying to like
figure [__] and I'm I'm like oh my God
like so here's the other thing about
this too that I'm now looking at the
business side of it if I'm a sex worker
most likely that's probably not a local
girl she's probably come in from
somewhere else because they know that
you guys are coming in from around the
world for the Super Cash heavy cash
heavy right card heavy too run it up as
much as we can they're probably all in
on it and they get guys like you and
probably slip my roofie or whatever it
is Xanax and their alcohol mix it black
out they're gone they don't remember it
boom they take it and then they're gone
it's not like you're going back to that
strip club and it's like come on trick
see we know what you did you know what I
mean you're never seeing them again and
I'm more worried about my dad than the
money
you know like I'm like
I don't know what to do
and I'm like again I'm close to my
family like I you know there's a
betrayal here I feel horrible
and I'm also like not remembering
anything like I'm sitting here with you
trying to like put together I don't have
any details like
and we go to the Super Bowl the next day
and you just don't go to the police you
don't report this no like I didn't even
know what that you could do that I
didn't tell the club anything like that
I just
you know it's right now as I'm telling
you I'm like how did I not do these
things but I was just like get out get
the hell out of here like
I don't know how this like does anyone
remember anything no one had an answer
how many people total with you like like
four and they got all of you and you all
woke up together and everything
everybody's sort of coming to at the
same time same time get out not weird
isn't that weird that is weird it's
almost timed that's weird yeah
[__] I felt so bad and then also like
the anxiety from drinking and you're
like again like
I I've blacked out I've gotten too drunk
we've all had those nights yeah but
we've done that to ourselves you got
robbed bro
like that that's something I won't even
admit today like that you got robbed
right because why do you feel
embarrassed so you got took like is it
about that ego thing I don't know I just
don't when you don't have the memory I
see you go like if I was held at
gunpoint
you'd go yeah I was right right I was
at a strip club drunk
but not I don't remember being that
you're saying the last thing you
remember was the they grabbed your car
and somebody's like let's do it and
you're like go ahead and that was it
that's the last that's the last thing
wow until you wake up wake up and
nothing's ever come back nothing's ever
come back receipt in my pocket 10 grand
yeah and I was like that's [__] crazy
and I wish to God it was my credit card
because then I'd just keep it a secret
when does it hit your dad's Windows like
so we go to the Super Bowl The Tyree
catch happens we're like yeah we need
this oh God I just need them to win I
need something good can you imagine the
Super Bowls to see them lose that's
probably the worst we're like we did
this in my mind I did this I'm the
reason
I'll never again
I was so mad
I never go where the stadium I just I
just like peeled my jersey I had a
jersey on I peeled it off and just put
it in my pocket like my back pocket I
was like I'm not getting [__] because it
was all New Yorkers too yeah back to the
New York east coast piece of [__] I
don't need [__] right now I'm down 10
grand and the page was just [__] lost
and the game of the century yes an epic
epic 17 and a one yeah 18-1 right was
that was what it was
a couple weeks go by and he
he gets the bill
and we didn't talk for a month
[Music]
and my dad did he not call or did he
call you and go hey this [__] [__]
happened oh then he called what no one
called the credit card company like look
my car got stolen this isn't we I
literally wanted away from this so I
again there's a lot of things I'm like
why didn't I do that like why didn't I
the adults
I think you know I was a you know I'd
say I was a child 23. I'm going
I just I'm more worried about my dad
than anything else like I'm not worried
about like
I don't know and and he would ask much
questions I remember just like I don't
have any answers and he's like are you
that [__] stupid like are you that
like and I felt so horrific then my
grandfather sent us there what happened
you know like and he my dad references
and anytime it comes up I get
embarrassed I can't talk about it like I
even now I'm like I'm feeling very like
I'm okay talking about it here because I
but I'm like
you know even now I'm like Ugh your dad
still does bring it up though he'll go
yeah it was just a good day until
you know like he [__] with me on it
yeah but like
it's real money you know like a lot of
money right I felt so bad and I still to
this day you know and you know you come
back and it's like
you know also because it wasn't like I
paid for my trip to the game you're like
Jared you're [__] loser like someone
gifted you the game of a lifetime and
you ruined a whole memory I mean listen
you did make the strippers night though
right someone's yeah some people went to
college
some tuition got paid yeah
right like I
I think back on that I'm like
there's no question in my mind that I
was drawn there's no question in my mind
that this was like the move it's Super
Bowl weekend of course
and I just like but I look back on that
I'm like I really you know you said
what's your low Point like
you know I've lived a very I have a very
lucky existence I ignite acknowledge
that fully I acknowledge that more now
because of doing comedy because
there's a lot of comedians that go and
try to like out sat each other when they
don't have a sad story to tell yeah that
frustrates me because I'm there with no
sad story to tell not doing that you
know so like this story is not a you
know
when you were like what are you I'm like
this is the only thing I can think of
you know I'm lucky in that sense like
I just remember the disappointment and
feeling and again
when I tell you I'm close with my family
like you know you almost lose that you
lose trust in them they don't want to
hang with you they don't want to be
around you they can't even look at you
these are people that you like is that
the longest time of not speaking a month
absolutely what made it what brought you
back together probably the holidays yeah
you know like you gotta go home you know
you got one where else am I gonna go
and then there's like a moment of like
bashfulness you know and then you know
time
but it was always like you know the next
year's Super Bowl
like every year that Tyree catch every
time there was a replay
I'm you know looking at the ground look
at it like twiddling my thumbs like a
[__] yeah I can't even look them in
the eye yeah I feel so bad
[Music]
you know what it is I'm not confident
enough to be like I was [__] robbed I
think it's a confidence thing because
have you ever told your dad that we've
never talked I just don't bring a wheel
I just I just I I don't want to bring it
up I never once said that look I'm I'm
embarrassed and I'm sorry but I'm
telling you we were robbed you never
even said that much
as a dad for me
I'd be like you still don't forget to
know that yeah right like I would hope
maybe maybe he just thinks you guys got
Buck Wild since uh you were drunk legit
nothing happened like legit
had a nap yeah right definitely did you
know yeah and I think I just think the
act of not remembering you go you get
self-conscious like what did I do maybe
I did something wrong and it's like no
no you fell asleep and you know if you
did something wrong if you didn't get
drugged and you were a big piece of [__]
at the strip club that place has cameras
everywhere they would have immediately
thrown you out and shown the cameras and
arrested us and they would have done
everything that I didn't do and also if
you just fell asleep you would have more
memory
if you just fell asleep and woke up you
had more you'd remember more of that
even I have no yeah
and then what maybe once before but
really inadvertently though like
the I took a drink at a bar that was
meant for a lady next to me first save
your life I mean I may have and it [__]
I mean gone and you all just lights out
lights out right threw up standing up
remember nothing else woke up the next
day in my home don't even know my
friends took care of me thank God but no
for sure
so it's it's scary
you know we're lucky to be alive so you
are you really are lucky to be like if
you think about it
um all right so I told you that at the
beginning of this um before we recorded
that I'll ask you advice you give to
your 16 year old self at the end of the
episode and this is what I'm curious
about sure we're there
what because you say you have you've let
a bit of a Charmed Life sure fortunate
what advice would you give to a 16 year
old Jared
um
it's advice I give to myself today you
know
we write to edit like I really believe
in that like
write it down it's not over
you're gonna be able to edit it
everything you do you write it down so
you can edit it like it's a work in
progress like it's gonna be okay and
then I don't mean interrupt but are you
saying that for comedy or for life I
started with comedy and I think it's for
life too I agree you know like it
started because my brother and I lived
together
in New York City and my brother is like
a more of a moody guy than I am you know
and he uh I say that sounds
sounds so vague then he hits me no
no
no it's just a moodier guys if you catch
my brother in a bad mood You're Gonna
Know It you catch me in a bad mood I'm
gonna avoid it yeah so
I would tell him bits and I could tell
when he's in a bad mood he'd be like
that's stupid and I'm like no no there's
nothing stupid
I'd be like no we write to edit I'm
telling you this
because it's not a finished product
that's right I'm telling you this
because I want to edit it I want to see
if I'm on the road
to better
you see where I'm going we write to edit
so that's again it started with that
with me saying that to him and then it
became everything we write to edit you
know listen that I
I feel horrible about I still like even
telling the story like it's like it
feels like a
like it hurts me to tell that story and
then I'm like you know what I definitely
learned from it you know I definitely
valued things a little bit differently
after that I definitely
valued you know family my relationships
differently from that were you a little
more careful with drinking in bars and
stuff after that yeah I'm a drinker just
generally like I don't smoke weed or
anything but I yeah definitely like but
are you a little more careful about
watching someone open a beer in front of
you as opposed to just getting a draft
on the car I I no
that sounds stupid now I am is it as of
today
what never really like wanted to unpack
this story like I've never like kind of
like told bits and pieces of it but I
never really wanted like unpack in a way
to go yeah Jared you were [__] robbed
you were drugged this is okay to like
admit like yeah dude but you know I
guess I always go to what did I do wrong
I always go to that like what did I
what am I gonna get in trouble for you
know like yeah and again like that's
like me at 16 and a half in the car I'm
sorry I hit you I don't know he was
looking the wrong [__] way I'd rather
be my fault and let's move on and I'll
be okay I'll give you the empathy that
maybe you won't give me mm-hmm you know
I think they've uh if I'm talking out
loud if I'm doing my giving myself the
therapy that's probably my first
instinct you know uh that's great yeah
hell yeah so
um well thank you for doing this this is
all this is a pleasure dude it's great
to finally meet you is you as well plug
and promote everything one more time
please 37 and single that's the special
it's on Netflix right now
um and then everything else I do is on
Instagram at Jared freed I yell at The
Bachelor I
um I'm always doing stupid [__] you know
like no one ever cast me in anything
so I was always casting myself and
coming up with [__] that something
was fun and people liked and some no one
cared about I would yell at charcuterie
call myself the board Lord
stupid [__] yeah so like uh so
everything I do is on Instagram and
Jared Frid there but 30 seconds I want
people to go watch the special and like
have fun with it yeah gender reveal bit
there's a neck bit there's a eating at
night I am like totally addicted I I
mean I have a story I would have told if
I didn't tell it there I love eating at
night
I just I like going to bed on a full
stomach
the way I grew up it just reminds me
today at least that I'm not poor and
then I got one more day in me
that is not how I think
I appreciate that you will think of it
that way but I'm definitely watching the
special go watch Jared special go watch
my special come see me on tour all
tickets are available Ryan sickler.com
and we'll talk to you all next week
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]